good we're rolling yo what's up my
name's samuel lees i'm standing right
here with my
mohammed this dude you're going to see
him real soon on winners wednesday i'm
around so many successful people
ricky ricky's successful scott's
successful i'm not sure what this
brother's done but he's easy
are you successful look man mohammed
here's my thinking mohammed i had this
vision of
of going to events in one of these
yeah but i can then just sleep while
we're while we're touring so let's see
let's look around
come on inside oh yeah on wheels
i absolutely love it
are you are you allowed to sleep while
you're driving
technically no right your honor but in
practice possibly
i reckon you could what would it what
would it feel like sleeping on here
you can do what you want to do okay
what's that when you own it you can do
whatever you want do you own it
yeah out for 1000 pounds a week
weekly rentals it's not bad
i'll wear it off yeah yeah yeah deal
100 we'll hire out for our tour next
month well whenever you're super when's
mo's got availability i love it so what
happens
yeah show me is this is your kitty size
bed
oh yo whoa whoa pops out you put the
cushion in
oh yeah this is becomes your bed yeah
okay big bed
yes sink cooker
fridge oven wardrobe
it's just a lot of space right toilet
shower did you buy this for you or did
you buy this to hire out
i bought this to hire it out really how
much you pay for
60 000 pounds 60 grand is it not going
to depreciate
i can't see how you're going to make
loads of money all right after around a
week so these
seems too cheap these don't depreciate
so much
okay so normal when you a new vehicle
lands
you lose a ton of load of money yeah not
with this
i'm going to swap it every every year
and get a new one
and it might depreciate by about four or
five grand you should keep doing it
yeah you change it every year so we
always have i love it i love it
and you can you can you can sit here do
some work you can do some work
work away you got a plug in there you
can plug in your chargers and everything
love it so the question is you can drive
this one
on your normal license question is
should i
hire it which i've already agreed i'm
going to do all right for a week well
maybe should i buy one
that's the question i guess i'll know
what's up hi there yeah
you will this dude you're going to see
him real soon on windows on a wednesday
because he doesn't just own
homes he also owns houses packages and
sales houses
top top dude so final words of wisdom
for my youtubers
get out there and do it just do it take
action
yeah make things happen hope you enjoyed
this video subscribe
like for more drop a comment see you
next time